you're not being present in your life
you're being present at all johan hari
he's been on a journey to understand
attention and why we seem to have so
little of it these days i know
something's really wrong but i don't
know what it is
and that's when i thought are we having
an attention and focus crisis if we are
why is it happening and most importantly
what can we do to get our brains back if
you've got all these smart engineers and
they've got one incentive how do i take
stephen's attention the absolute most i
can we need an attention movement to
reclaim our minds if our goal is as a
country to be a country that's
innovative my god a country of people
who can think is going to be innovative
country of adult people flicking between
whatsapp snapchat and tick tock ain't
going to be a place full of innovation
do you want your child to be able to
focus do you want your child to be able
to read books do you want your child to
be able to think deeply of course you do
okay we've got to fix the society and
culture to give them those things and we
absolutely can change them
quick one can you do me a favor if
you're listening to this and hit the
subscribe button the follow button
wherever you're listening to this
podcast thank you so much today
one of my favorite ever guests on this
podcast returns
and they return with a completely
different conversation for you
johan hari
what he wrote about mental health and
the causes of depression and anxiety and
meaningful connection
changed my life it's probably the number
one book i recommend and you've heard me
recommend on this podcast the book lost
connections but over the last several
years johan's been on a completely
different journey he's been on a journey
to understand attention and why we seem
to have so little of it these days but
why it's so fundamentally important for
our happiness our success and everything
in between we all know we're a
generation that are glued to our screens
and our phone
but what is the cost what is the cost of
things that actually matter how do we
change it why should we change it johan
went on that journey
the most remarkable entertaining
hilarious journey and he's unbelievable
maybe the best ever on this podcast
storyteller you're gonna absolutely love
this conversation and
entertainment aside
it might just change your life
so without further ado i'm stephen
bartlett and this is the diary of a ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
johan
first and foremost thank you for coming
back i it just dawned on me that you
visited here more than any other guest
you now have the record as three times
we've had i mean i'm officially the king
of your you're the king of my podcast
and my my first question to you is i
know how talented you are at writing and
how
um you could basically write about
anything if you wanted to because your
books have been so successful you're a
very very well acclaimed um author
so my first question is
and this is the question i asked myself
when i received your book from your
publisher is why did you decide to write
about attention when you could have
spent your life writing about anything
you know for years i had this feeling
like when i walked around in my friends
in myself
something was going badly wrong with our
ability to focus and pay attention and
every now and then i would see small
studies that seem to suggest this was
true there's a study of american college
students that found that now they only
focus on average on any one thing for 65
seconds there's a study of office
workers that found on average now office
workers only focus on one task for three
minutes
but i thought
people have always felt their attention
is getting worse right what happens as
you get older
you know your attention deteriorates and
you mistake your own deterioration for
the deterioration of the world around
you right you can read stories of monks
in the middle ages uh letters they wrote
to each other saying oh my attention
isn't what it used to be i'm worried
about this right so i just thought uh
everyone thinks this and then there was
a it was a moment that for me i thought
i do think there's something deeper
happening here
when he was nine my godson adam
developed this brief but really
freakishly intense obsession with elvis
i never found out why he must have seen
him on on youtube or the telly or
something and he he didn't know
that like elvis impersonation has become
this cheesy thing so he did it with this
totally like heart catching sincerity he
would sing viva las vegas and suspicious
minds and and all the kind of elvis
classics
and um
he kept getting me to tell him the story
of elvis that elvis is born in this
little town called tupelo in mississippi
and one of the poorest places in america
he's born and his twin brother died as
he was being born and as he was a little
boy his mother told him that if he
looked at the moon and he sang his
little brother could hear him so that's
why he became one of the reasons he
became such a great singer so i was
telling my god son this story and what
and i
obviously told him that elvis became
really famous and bought this palace
that he called graceland and one day i
was tucking tucking him in
and he said to me looked at me very
intensely and he said johann
will you take me to graceland one day
and i said yeah sure in the way you do
with little children you're just like
you know they're never gonna forget it
the next day and he said no do you
really promise will you take me to
graceland
and i said yeah i promise you
i didn't think about it again for 10
years until really everything had gone
wrong
so by the time adam was 19
he dropped out of school when he was 15
and he was
just spent he seemed to spend just all
his time alternating between his ipad
his laptop and his phone
and he seemed to live in this kind of
blur
of whatsapp and youtube and porn
and
it was like he had fragmented as a
person
it was like he was kind of whirring at
the speed of snapchat right you couldn't
have a conversation with him lasted more
than a few minutes he was very
intelligent decent not good person
but it was like nothing could gain any
friction in his mind and one day we were
sitting on my sofa
and i was looking at him doing this and
i was thinking god in the decade that
you've become a man
this has happened to so many people i
know okay this is the extreme end of the
spectrum but i could feel it happening
to myself right
things that require deep focus like
reading a book obviously i still do that
a huge amount but it felt like with
every year that passed that was more and
more like running up a down escalator
right some people can still get to the
top but and the escalator is getting
faster right
and i was looking at him and i thought i
have to break this routine i can't bear
to see this happen to him i can't bear
to feel this happened to myself and i
suddenly remembered when he'd been a
little boy and i said you know what
let's go to graceland
and he looked at me like what are you
talking about he didn't even remember
this elvis obsession and i was like no
i'll take you to graceland let's go
let's just leave but i'll take you on
one condition
which is that when we go there you leave
your phone in the hotel when we go out
right
because i can't take you there and just
you be looking at your phone the whole
time
so two weeks later we flew we went to
new orleans first but we left from
heathrow and we and we we flew out to
the south and when you arrive at the
gates of graceland now this is
pre-covered i imagine it's worse now but
when you arrive at the gates of
graceland there isn't a physical guide
to show you around anymore what happens
is they give you an ipad
and you put in uh little uh earphones
and the ipad shows you around so you
look at the ipad and it says go left and
then there's an actor telling you like
in this room and it explains all these
things and in each room you're in
there's like a representation of that
room on the ipad
so what happens is people walk around
graceland staring at their ipad right
so i'm walking around
surrounded by this kind of united
nations of blank-faced people from like
korea and canada and everywhere else and
no one is looking at the thing they've
traveled
to see right
and i'm getting more and more like tense
as i'm watching this and i'm trying to
make eye contact with someone to go like
oh you know
someone i'm waiting for someone else to
look up and go look we're the people who
traveled 3000 miles and actually looked
at the thing we traveled to
and finally i did make eye contact with
a guy and i smiled and i was about to
say exactly what i just said and then i
realized he'd only taken the earphones
out and put down the ipad so he could
take out his phone and take a selfie
and i was feeling more and more tense
and finally we got to the jungle room
which was elvis favorite room in
graceland it's just a kind of fake
jungle with loads of fake plants
and there's this couple next to me
and the man turned to his wife and said
honey look this is amazing
if you swipe left you can see the jungle
room to the left and if you swipe right
you can see the jungle room to the right
she goes oh wow and so she's swiping
left and right on her ipad and i look at
this guy and i said
right but sir there's an old-fashioned
form of swiping you can do
it's called turning your head because
we're actually in the jungle room right
you don't need to look at a digital
representation of it we're literally
here look it's in front of you and of
course this couple thought i was insane
not possibly not unreasonably and they
they walked off
and i turned to my godson to kind of
bond with him and laugh about isn't this
mad and he was just standing in a corner
looking at snapchat from because the
minute we le we landed he just was on
his phone constantly i remember when i
said to him i thought you said you
weren't going to use your phone he said
oh i thought you meant i won't take
phone calls i can't not use social media
right and it was he said it was a kind
of baffled sincerity as if i was asking
him to hold his breath or something i
got really angry and i said to him you
know you're frightened of missing out
but what this is doing is it's
guaranteeing you miss out you're not
being present in your life you're being
present
at all and he kind of stormed off again
not unreasonably i was being a bit angry
and so i stomped around graceland on my
own for a while and then that night i
found out we were staying in the
heartbreak hotel which is across the
street from graceland and i found him
there's a swimming pool that's shaped
like a guitar where they play all these
songs in a constant loop and i saw him
sitting there looking at his phone and i
went up to him
and i realized like a lot of anger my
anger at him was really angry at myself
i could feel these pressures happening
to me
i could feel my own attention and focus
fragmenting
and he just looked at his phone and said
i know something's really wrong
but i don't know what it is
and that's when i thought okay i need to
look into
are we having an attention and focus
crisis if we are why is it happening and
most importantly what can we do to get
our brains back
and what did you discover in terms of
the stats facts and figures around the
attention crisis is it a real thing
is it is it happening and and link to
that i guess what is the
what are we losing because of the
attention crisis
yeah so i ended up traveling all over
the world i interviewed 250 of the
leading experts in the world about
attention and focus and i went to just
places that have been really differently
affected by this so from moscow to miami
from a favela islamic in rio de janeiro
where attention had collapsed in a
particularly disastrous way to an office
in new zealand where they discovered
this amazing way to restore people's
attention and what i learned is so the
best way we could know if attention has
collapsed would be if for the last 150
years
every year scientists are given the same
kind of attention test to people and
then we'd be able to track it that way
no one did that so that that we don't
know that but i do think there's another
way we can reasonably conclude that this
is a real crisis so there's scientific
evidence for 12 different factors that
affect attention and focus but either
boost it or trash it
and there's good evidence that a lot of
these factors have been rising
throughout your lifetime and my lifetime
so i think it's fair to conclude
therefore that we are facing a real
crisis and there's various pieces of
evidence that do show collectively our
attention span really is shrinking so
and i think that leads to um we've got
to understand what's happening to us in
a very different way because when i felt
my attention fraying
my main response was to go into
you know just self-criticism just go
you're weak you're lazy you're not good
enough why aren't you strong enough to
resist these forms of distraction and
actually when you know that this is
happening to almost all of us
or in fact these factors are bearing on
all of us right they're affecting some
of us differently that made me realize
you've got to think about this in it in
a different way so there's a guy i went
to interview one of the leading experts
on children's attention problems in the
world a guy named professor joel nigg
who's uh in portland and oregon
and he said to me look think about
obesity right if you look at a beach
a photograph of a beach in britain in
1970 or in the us anywhere
everyone is by our standards either slim
or buff there's nobody who's what we
think of as fat right no one it's really
weird and it's not that fat people just
stayed at home right
what happened is if you look at 1970
there was almost no obesity in the
western world and then certain
absolutely crucial changes happened in
the way we live right our food supply
change people used to eat fresh and
nutritious food we moved to heavily
processed and ultra processed food which
affects your body in a very different
way and our city's completely changed so
you used to be able to bike and walk
to work to the places you wanted to go
in a lot of our cities that's now
impossible and as a result of these two
big changes and some other ones actually
stress right the more stressed you are
the more you want it comforting as a
result of these big changes obesity
exploded so it's not that individuals
got like weak or whatever we might
whatever the stigmatizing these people
say about overweight people
and
what professor nick said is something
very similar is happening with attention
there are changes in the way we live
that are pouring acid on everyone's
ability to pay attention
um the way he put it the kind of
technical term is that we have a an
attentional pathogenic culture a culture
in which it is very hard for all of us
to form and sustain deep focus this is
why um activities that require deep
forms of focus like reading a book have
just fallen off a cliff right in the
last 20 years
so what we've got to do is there's two
levels of response one is there are
individual responses there are changes
we can all make in our lives obviously i
talk about this a lot in the book stolen
focus about this there are changes we
can all make in our lives
there are also
big changes we need to make as a society
so we need to come together and demand
changes in the society that would make
it possible for us to make a lot of
these positive changes we want to make
so these two layers i mean i know
there's a lot there to um but okay so if
we were to agree that um attention has
decayed
what i really want to know is um like so
what what what is the cost to my life
outside of the fact that i might not
have as engaging relationships is there
any other cost to my productivity to
anything else that really really matters
to me yeah this is such an important
question i think there's two sort of
levels we need to think about it the
first is as an individual
if you can't focus and pay attention
your ability to achieve your goals
across the board diminishes right so you
want to set up a business you want to
write a book you want to learn how to
play the guitar
all of those things become much harder
if you can't focus and pay attention if
you're constantly pulled away by the you
know pings in your phone well let's say
you want to be a good parent
if you're constantly pulled away from
that if you're constantly distracted
your ability to do that so any goal you
have in your life
is diminished if you can't pay attention
and so that's the personal layer there's
also just a collective and social layer
if you live in a society where people
can't pay attention if you're surrounded
by people who can't pay attention our
ability to solve our collective problems
and we're facing a lot of collective
problems at the moment also breaks down
so attention is crucial for achieving
goals and problem solving and to me
those are the two of the most important
things in life right and you went to the
other one just being present with people
right you know if you can't be present
with people if you think about my godson
you can't form the deepest relationships
you have if most of us think about if i
said to you you know what's a moment
that's been deeply meaningful to you in
your life
it'll be a moment but very likely when
you are paying attention and other
people are paying attention to you right
it's a moment of shared focus a moment
of meaning
um we can't do that if we can't pay
attention so you become a sort of
stump of yourself there's a you know you
can sense that you might have been more
it chokes off growth and there's there's
kind of
there's a few ways of thinking about
this
there's an amazing expert on attention
called dr james williams who interviewed
in moscow it's a former google engineer
who said that there's a few kind of
different types of attention that we see
and we seem to be losing all of them so
the first type of attention is called
your spotlight right so let's say
there's a fridge in the corner of this
room let's say uh i want to go and get
two drinks from that and bring it to the
people in the other room right so my
spotlight i've got an immediate task go
and get the drinks take them to the
people in the other room now if i'm
constantly interrupted if i'm constantly
checking my text i might get to the
fridge get a little text forget why did
i go there again the guys in the room
are saying where the hell's johan why
has he not brought us this stuff so your
spotlight is your ability to home in on
an immediate task right
that is obvious we can all see how
that's being disrupted i can talk more
about that if you like
then there's what he calls your
starlight which is your more medium-term
goals so a medium-term goal might be you
know a goal that you obviously had a few
years ago i want to start a business
right that's a medium term goal it's
called starlight because when you're not
sure where you are you look up at the
stars and you're like oh you orientate
yourself by the stars right
that is being disrupted if your life is
full of distractions if your
consciousness is hijacked by really
petty goals or goals that are someone
else's goals like social media
you you can't you lose you begin to lose
your ability to formulate it's not just
you can't achieve the short-term tasks
you lose your ability to achieve your
longer-term tasks and the third form is
what james calls dr williams calls your
daylight which is how do you even know
that you want to set up a business how
do you even know what it means to be a
good dad how do you know what it means
to have a good life right
for to be able to see clearly a room has
to be flooded with daylight
and it's not just that we're losing our
short-term attention it's not just that
we're losing our medium-term attention
when those things happen
you you have less ability to make sense
of your own life you know he compared it
to on the internet a denial of service
attack where when someone wants to take
down a website they get you know many
thousands of computers to log on
simultaneously and the computer crashes
it's like we're experiencing that we're
so overloaded that your sense of like
who am i what do i want to do if you're
if your life is atrophied into 65 second
and three-minute chunks
how do you build a sense of where you
want to go and who you want to be you
begin to feel lost in your own life and
i think you can see that happening to
lots of people i certainly can and as
you were saying do you feel that for
yourselves oh 100
and as you were saying that i was
reflecting on um how difficult i find it
to just sit with my girlfriend and just
like pay attention and just try and
connect with her like how has your day
been without devices and screens and
there was a there was a big change we
made together where we kind of made a
rule that we would exclude devices from
certain parts of our life so we don't
have them in the bedroom if we're in if
we're in bed together we don't have
devices in there and um there'll be some
times where we commit to putting the
phones away and doing something
sometimes for seven hours so it'll be
like she'll say to me i want to do this
special type of dance that i've never
done before right
so put the phones away and as i'm doing
it especially at the start as we're
doing this like there's called contact
dance you wanted to do with me where you
always maintain one point of contact
i was just thinking about my phone and
then
you know i think we get into hour five
and six and i'm still thinking about my
phone and it's funny because i'm not
being present i'm not i'm actually kind
of like
complying with what she wants to do so
that i can get back to my phone and i
find that really really sad and it's
actually i can see how it would
jeopardize the chance of a really
meaningful connection in modern
relationships where you're never really
connected i think a lot of relationships
are actually more connected on social
media than they are in
in real life and i wonder if that's had
an adverse effect on the success of
relationships
this uh this this absence of focus and
attention
i think there's so many important things
in what you just said so what you've um
built for you and your girlfriend there
your first response is a good first
response which is um for an individual
level there's big collective ones as
well but an individual level a good
response is what's called pre-commitment
so what you do is you said you and your
girlfriend say we're gonna put our phone
away for seven hours right so you say it
in advance and there's a woman called
professor molly crockett at yale
university where i interviewed as kind
of expert on pre-commitment so
pre-commitment is we all know
there's all sorts of things you want to
do
that you know you might crack and give
in later and not achieve them right so i
don't want to eat any pringles right
because they make me even fatter than i
am right so the best form of
pre-commitment is when i go to the
supermarket don't buy the pringles right
because i buy the pringles and tell
myself i'll just have fun i'll have five
tonight and of course you get to 2am you
wake up you're [ __ ] chugging them
like homer simpson right so the one
point pre-commitment there is a don't
buy the pringles b
tell everyone you're not going to buy
the pringles because even just
articulating your goal out loud makes
you more likely to achieve it so you've
got one form of pre-commitment there
right you've said okay we're going to
say to each other we've got seven hours
now we're going to put the phone away
so that's a really good model of
pre-commitment but also
you've got to one of the challenges with
that which is your you know your you you
feel like your consciousness has been
hijacked by by these technologies and it
was really interesting researching this
because a lot of people when i say i've
done a book about attention and focus
they say oh you've written a book about
tech actually texts only about 20 of
what's going on i think although it's a
very important 20
and and it was really interesting
researching this because
actually
it's not
most of the problem is not inherent to
the technology
it's the result of something else which
is actually more fixable because you and
me we're not going to give away our
phones nor nor should we right we're not
going to abandon this technology
we could make the technology work for
our attention rather than against it so
i spent a lot of time in silicon valley
interviewing the people a lot of the
people who designed the world in which
we now live right
and really feel bad about it and
they are they have all the problems that
you me and everyone watching have
there's a really james williams the
google engineer who i just mentioned
there was an incredible moment when he
spoke at a tech conference so he's
speaking entirely to really influential
designers who are making the stuff that
we're all using and he said to them
is there anyone here in the audience
who wants to live in the world that
we're creating put up your hand
and not one of them did
another one of them tristan harris an
amazing
dissident in silicon valley who also
worked for google he worked on the gmail
team
when they were designing gmail and you
know spreading it to the whole world and
one day he was in the googleplex and one
of his colleagues said i've got an idea
because they were trying to figure out
figure out how to get more and more
people to use gmail more so one day i
had an idea he just said why don't we
make it
so that every time someone gets an email
their phone vibrates and everyone in the
team said that's a good idea
and tristan
a week later was walking around san
francisco
and just heard these vibrations
everywhere
and thought
[ __ ] we did that
and that's happening
everywhere within a few months he did
calculation
there were 11 billion distractions
every day being caused by his company
right so these people are really open to
there's a big obviously a big debate
about this
but there was a moment and there's lots
of things to say about it and lots of
techniques these social companies use to
maximally hijack your attention and we
can talk about those techniques and i
think there's loads we need to learn
about that but actually to me the most
important thing the root of this is to
understand that social media doesn't
have to work that way and the moment
that really helped me to understand it i
was really struggling with getting my
head around that if i open facebook
it'll tell me all sorts of things it'll
say oh it's you you make rob's birthday
today um this is something you said five
years ago
there's been a terrorist attack and look
these people have marked themselves as
safe i don't tell you all sorts of
things
what it won't do is something that
actually lots of people would really
love there's no button on facebook that
says
i'd like to meet up with my mates who's
free now who's nearby and available
right now that's technologically
unbelievably easy facebook could design
that in an hour right that would be
really popular i'm sure everyone
listening thinks yeah that'd be a really
handy thing to have um it doesn't exist
why does the market not provide it if
you follow the chain
from why the market doesn't provide it i
think you begin to understand some of
the ways our attention are being invaded
and how we can get it back
so when you open facebook facebook makes
money in two ways
first way is very obvious you see ads we
all understand how that works the second
way is much more valuable to facebook
everything you do on facebook everything
you like everything you dislike
everything you message to people is
scanned and sorted by their ai
technology
to build a profile of you right so let's
say that you like kylie minogue and
donald trump and you message your mum
going i've just bought a load of nappies
right okay so the ai is figuring out
okay this person is probably gay no
disrespect to heterosexual fans of kylie
probably out there this person's gay
they're quite right-wing and they've got
a baby because why would they be
messaging about nappies right so think
about thousands and thousands of data
points like that it's building up a very
complicated and detailed profile of you
which it then sells to advertisers so
they can target you because if you're if
you're
making nappies you don't want to send an
ad to me i don't have any children
you've wasted your money you want to
target your advertising so facebook is
making money
every moment you open it facebook makes
money through those two revenue streams
and every time you put
the facebook app down or you shut your
phone off
facebook loses money right or they don't
make the money they would make if you
carried on scrolling right that's it
that's their business model it's simply
that
once you understand that
you can see why there's no button that
says who's available and wants to meet
up now because if you push that button
and it said oh joe's around the corner
i'll go for a coffee with joe
you and joe would sit opposite each
other and talk to each other right well
then you're not on facebook they're
losing money their entire business model
as sean parker who was one of the first
investors in facebook said
our whole business model was to hack
people's attention we knew we were doing
it and we did it anyway so they have the
most sophisticated engineers in the
world
specifically working to figure out
maximally how to hack your attention but
the thing that blew my mind about this
because you can get into okay you talk
about that and
very often this is framed as
oh okay so is this an anti-tech or pro
are we pro-tech or anti-tech are we
it's completely wrong way to think about
it the question is not are you pro-tech
or anti-tech the question is what tech
working in whose interests right
because that business model which is
designed has to be about fracking your
attention that's that's the only way it
can work
is not the only business model for these
companies right so let's say acer asking
one of the who designed key aspects of
the internet that we now use amazing guy
said to me we should just ban that
business model right a business model
that is based on tracking you
surveilling you invading your attention
and selling that attention to the
highest bidder that is just an
inhuman way of doing it it's like lead
in pain
ban it so i said well what to all these
people what happens the day after we ban
it right so what do i open facebook and
it just says sorry close
no what would happen is all these
companies would have to move to other
business models which already exist so
one model might be subscription you know
like netflix we don't know how
subscription works or it might be that
we choose to own it together somewhere
beneath where we're sitting there's a
sewer right we own that sewer you and me
as taxpayers own that sewer together
because when we didn't have sewers we
had [ __ ] in the street and we got
cholera and people died and then
together we built the sewers and
together we own and maintain the sewers
because it's important for all of us now
it might be we want to say just like we
own the sewer pipes together we might
want to own the information pipes
together because at the moment we're
getting the equivalent of cholera for
our attention right but the key thing
about that is when you move to these
different models
instead of you being the product right
today you're not the customer of
facebook you're the product they sell to
advertisers
if we move to those different business
models suddenly you're the person they
want to please right if you want to pay
attention they could start des
redesigning facebook in all sort of ways
sorts of ways very practical ways i can
tell you about lots of them
that are designed not to hack your
attention but are designed to heal your
attention and designed to make your life
better she looks really interesting so
obviously my background is social media
so um been
knee deep in this industry for a long
long time and in 2019 mark zuckerberg
wrote a letter where he said he posted
on his facebook saying um we've done
some studies we've spoken to some people
and we've discovered that the timeline
is bad for you it's net negative
predominantly because of these highly
addictive very short viral videos i'm
gonna put my hands up that was part of
the company i built business model we
were we built we had huge huge facebook
pages some of which had tens of millions
of followers and we knew that if we
wanted a ton of views which would result
in a ton of followers we had to post
very very short highly engaging short
videos facebook that year
changed the timeline they killed that
bit that part of our business model
where these like super addictive viral
videos would no longer work and in their
little statement they said the things
that will now work are any content that
gets people to basically just have
conversation with each other so we then
tested that and buzzfeed tested that as
well buzzfeed posted some things and
discovered that if your post is dis
discussion worthy it will now do better
and so is facebook were apparently
trying to do the right thing
um
which cost them that year their revenues
i believe went down that year their
stock price definitely did and they
pointed to listen we made these changes
to our to our timeline
our news feed to try and make it more
healthy
something else emerged
and that thing which is now the dominant
force is called tick-tock and tick-tock
took the place of short addictive as
[ __ ] you don't even know your scrolling
videos and the way that i know it from
my social media background that tiktok
have fully owned that space is simple on
my tic toc now say i have a hundred
thousand followers a video can get 1 000
views or a million views the variance of
viewership is extreme what that means is
they are the algorithm is just taking
the most addictive things and saying
[ __ ] everything else it's like i'm not
gonna show your followers or the the
discovery feed the thing you posted that
wasn't addictive i'm just gonna grab the
viral stuff
that's super short and put that in the
feed so now i was talking to some of my
colleagues today fortunately i don't
actually use tik tok like i don't use it
myself i have a tick tock but i don't
use it myself to engage with friends and
every single one of my friends some of
them are sat in this room now some of
them are downstairs they describe their
relationship with tick-tock as like
as if it's heroin like i've never heard
a social network described in such a way
my friend dash who's like 35
he goes i'll just touch the app and he
goes an hour's gone and he's like i've
never seen anything like it so if
facebook change
my point here is that some i've seen how
someone else who just doesn't give a
[ __ ] will come and occupy that space
make a billion dollars and
um and run off and so i'm like oh you
know but this is why we you're totally
right this is why we need to look at the
business model for social media and
whether we allow or not of course
think about lead paint again right so
presumably there was a market leader in
lead paint in the 70s
and let's say the responsible paint just
would go you this individual company
needs to stop manufacturing lead paint
of course someone else would have just
come along and made lead paint that's
not the solution
solution is to say no no one can put
lead in paint right which is not to say
there can't be social media that
absolutely can social media has lots of
great things about it but it's about
saying do you have a business model that
is designed about maximally invading
people's attention
or do you have a business model
that's about uh giving people what they
want most people do not what like you're
saying your friends they push the button
and it's gone for now most people don't
want that right most tick tock users i
think about my nieces using tick tock
all the time she doesn't want that
either so at the moment we have a model
that's about hacking people and giving
them what they don't want to sell them
to advertisers when you get rid of that
business model which they won't do
spontaneously we have to make them do it
right
that it produces a completely different
dynamic i so i'm keen so you put your i
read in the book you basically put your
phone in a box and then
escaped to the phone you must have been
more productive than ever because of
this thing that people described called
being in the flow state right i imagine
if i'm distraction free then i'll be in
that flow state longer i i heard about
this concept of a flow state maybe about
a year or two ago and then i i could i
could relate to it because i've had
those moments in my work or when i'm
doing a certain activity specifically
more like monotonous activities or
repetitive activities where you get into
that state of flow where you're almost
doing it without thinking what is flow
and
how do you find it and what is the power
of being in one's flow state so a flow
state
is when you're everyone listening will
have experienced at some point in their
life a flow state is when you're doing
something that's really meaningful to
you and you really get into it
and your sense of time falls away your
sense of ego falls away and your
attention to it just feels effortless
right so one rock climber put it
it's like you get into flowing rock
climbing when you feel like you are the
rock you're climbing right so we all
will have had moments of flow in our
lives what's really important about flow
in relation to attention
is this is a power this is a capacity
that all human beings have
and it's a capacity
where
you can pay attention to something
deeply but it doesn't feel like an
effort right it's not like studying for
an exam where you're like
okay so napoleon was born there okay you
know you can you can pay attention that
way but that's an effort
flow is like a gusher of attention that
is inside all of us that that we can pay
so obviously mahali spent
professor chick sent me high he sent
spent 40 years of his life more than
actually 50 years of his life studying
flow states
how do they happen how do we maintain
them what ruins them
and and
he discovered lots of amazing things
about it he discovered that actually
flow states are really essential for
having a good life for feeling competent
for for good mental health
and he discovered he made lots of
discoveries but for me there were three
really important things he discovered
about how to get into a flow
state firstly you have to choose one
goal if you're trying to do lots of
things at the same time you will not get
into flow i can explain why later
that's really important you have to
choose one thing right
the second thing you have to do
is you have to choose a goal that is
meaningful to you if it's not meaningful
you'll never get into flow on it for me
it would be writing right but everyone
will have something
and thirdly
you need to choose something that is
ideally at the edge of your abilities so
let's say you're a rock climber let's
say you're a medium talent rock climber
right if you just clamber over garden
wall
you're not going to get into a state of
flow equally if you suddenly try and
climb mount kilimanjaro it's going to be
overwhelming you're also not going to
get into a state of flow what you want
to do is choose something that's a
little bit harder
than the thing the time you did last
time right so flow begins at the edge of
your abilities so you want those those
three things one clear goal it's got to
be meaningful to you and it's got to be
the edge of your abilities if you do
that you
there's no guarantee but you max
massively increase your chance of
getting into flow which is this form of
deep meaningful attention but mahali
also made a discovery he discovered this
in the late 80s
the um
there's something that absolutely
consistently ruins flow which is being
interrupted being distracted right just
kills flow dead which kills the deepest
form of attention and i think we're
really living
and mahali thought that we're really
living with a crisis of flow states now
what is the harm of interruption i i
read in your book about the the decaying
creativity and the time it takes to get
back into the task once you've done it
but is there a more sort of
um
consequential so if you want to
understand and this might sound when i
first describe it like a small effect
i'm going to explain how big it is
afterwards because don't feel big when
you're doing it so i went to interview
one of the leading neuroscientists in
the world of my name professor earl
miller who's mit the massachusetts
institute of technology
and professor miller said to me
you have to understand one crucial thing
about your brain my brain everyone's
brains
you can only think consciously about one
thing at a time
this is just a fundamental limitation of
the human brain human brain hasn't
changed in 40 000 years ain't going to
change any time soon you can only think
about one thing at a time
but we have fallen for a mass delusion
so the average teenager according to a
study by professor larry rosen believes
they can now follow seven forms of media
at the same time
so what happens when you believe you're
you're you're doing lots of things at
once so they get people into labs they
get them to do think they're doing lots
of things at once and see what happens
and it turns out
there are four
really big costs that happen
so the first is what's called the switch
cost effect
so let's say my phone is outside this
room but let's say i have my phone in my
pocket right let's say you were just
talking you spoke for a minute or two
what you said was really interesting
let's imagine that i had just taken out
my phone and glanced at my text messages
for a few seconds while you were doing
that right
kind of thing that happens all the time
you think oh i've just taken two seconds
and i'll
in that moment i have to refocus my
brain oh
um jess texted me oh right so that must
mean that her
mum needs to oh right okay you've got it
and then i have to re-focus on you wait
what was stephen just saying again
seems like a small effect it's not i'll
talk about how much it is in a minute
the the second uh cost it it brings in
is you start to make mistakes when
you're switching between things it
massively increases your error rate so
say that i'm i don't know doing my tax
return and i look at my text and i go
back to my tax return i'm much more
likely to make mistakes and that means i
have to go back and correct my mistakes
the third effect is on your memory so to
translate your experiences into memories
it takes mental effort right takes a
certain amount of brain power if your
brain is instead just jammed up with all
this switching
the evidence shows you're significantly
less likely to just remember what
happened you're less likely to remember
any of it and the the third effect is on
your creativity so
when you just have time to think
your brain naturally wanders and it will
roam over you know things people have
said to you in your life moments you've
had
things you've read a whole range of
things and it will start to make
connections between those things that's
actually what creativity is it's when
two ideas that have never been put
together go together and pop right you
know that's much better than me
but when your brain is jammed up with
switching
it just doesn't get the space to do that
right and i've heard that i'm thinking
speaking to president miller who's an
amazing man and just thinking
all right i get that but that's quite
small right when i looked at the studies
i was quite struck hewlett-packard you
know the people who make printers well
they're [ __ ] printers that always jam
in my experience but anyway
hewlett-packard did a quite small
experiment with their workers
so they split them into two groups and
the first group was told
just do whatever task you've got to do
today and you're not going to be
interrupted and the second group was
told just do your tasks today and they
were interrupted with emails and texts
right what was described as a heavy
amount of emails and texts
and then they just tested their iq
after either not being distracted or
being distracted what they found is the
people who have been distracted
tested are having 10 iq points lower
than the people who had not been
distracted right because it makes you
less intelligent constantly switching
the strain of that makes you less
intelligent and to give you a sense of
what 10 iq points means
if you and me smoke to spliff now
together
our iq would drop by about five points
so it's double just being heavily
interrupted it has double the effect on
your intelligence and attention as
getting stoned so you would be better
off sitting at your desk doing one thing
and smoking a spliff then sitting at
your desk not smoking a spliff and being
interrupted all the time there's a guy
called professor michael posner at the
university of oregon who found that if
you are distracted and pulled away
it takes you 20 and go back to the task
you were doing originally it takes you
23 minutes to get back to the same level
of focus as you had before right so
we're all our focus is being stolen the
book is called stolen focus for this
reason our focus is being stolen by
these forces that's just one of the
twelve there's loads of them but
we've got to understand this
and the other point i guess so you write
about in this book which is i was
surprised you linked to attention
because it wasn't an obvious link to me
was about
sleep
and and the decay in
um our sleeping
health over
decades and you you write that we're
sleeping less than ever before and we're
having worse sleep than ever before my
sleep is fairly good but it i think it's
decaying i'd say it's decaying um i
sleep with my phone in my bed first
thing i do when i wake up in the morning
i'm actually as i'm opening my eyes i'm
thinking about where i need to put my
hand to get the phone
like i'm visualizing where i think i
left it and my brain always knows my
brain's like it's over by your right
your right ear yeah yeah it always knows
where it is and then i wake up i look at
what's that
100 notifications 100 things um
what's the you know what's the cost of
this type of behavior which i think a
lot of people will resonate for and what
is the like macro trend in sleep health
yeah this is one of the 12 causes i
write about in in stolen focus that
really
uh the evidence was quite shocking
actually so i interviewed lots of
experts but i interviewed arguably the
leading expert in the world on sleep a
man named dr charles seisler who's at
harvard medical school he's taught
everyone from the boston red sox to the
secret service about about sleep
and he started to make this breakthrough
in 1981 so he
when charles was a medical school he was
taught
that um
basically when you're asleep your brain
is just inert it's not doing much so he
starts doing this research nothing to do
with sleep it was it's not really
doesn't matter what it's about but it
was about the time of day that the body
releases a particular hormone and to
study that he had to keep people awake
in a lab right for quite long periods of
time so he's working with them and he's
got all sorts of techniques for keeping
them awake like attention techniques and
he was just immediately struck when he's
doing this
how quickly and how dramatically
people's attention and ability to think
deteriorated as they stayed awake longer
if you're awake for 19 hours it doesn't
feel like very long
your attention and ability to think is
the same as if you were legally drunk
right so your your attention things that
would take
a fraction of a second when you're
refreshed and alert he was discovering
if you were awake for just a day we're
taking 12 seconds a staggering increase
in your ability to think so you start to
think oh i should study sleep i should
look into this and he began to do
a series of hugely groundbreaking
research on sleep what he did is he
pioneered putting together two bits of
technology there's a kind of technology
that can scan your eyes to see what
you're looking at and obviously there's
pet scans and things that can scan your
brain and see what's happening in your
brain
so he put this together
and he looked at people who were tired
not that tired but tired
um to see what they were looking at and
what was happening in their brain as
they looked at it and what he discovered
is that you when you're tired you could
appear to be awake
as awake as you and me seem now you can
be looking at people you can be talking
but parts of your brain have literally
gone to sleep it's called local sleep
because it's local to one part of the
brain right
which is kind of mind-blowing this helps
to explain why attention degrades
so rapidly when you're asleep and i was
trying why is that what's going on there
i mean it's also important to bear in
mind this is one of the ways we know
attention has got worse there's good
evidence that sleep has dramatically
deteriorated we sleep on average an hour
less
than people did in 1942 and children
sleep 80 minutes a night less than they
did a century ago so it's a staggering
there's been a 20 decline in adult sleep
in the last century incredible figures
and when you look at them they're kind
of mind-blowing um only 15 percent of
people wake up feeling refreshed so i
wanted to understand why is this right
what why does sleep affect our attention
so much one of people are interviewed
about this and looked at her research
very carefully it's an amazing woman
called professor roxanne prichard who's
at the university of minneapolis where i
interviewed her she explained to me when
you don't sleep your body interprets it
as an emergency it says something's
really wrong here right
he's not sleeping why isn't he sleeping
so it has all sorts of physiological and
psychological effects it raises your
heart rate it makes you crave more sugar
and fast food because it'll release
glucose quickly
it makes your heart beat faster and it
shuts down a lot of the creative parts
of your brain a lot of the more fertile
parts of your brain it's like it's an
emergency you haven't got time to worry
about that you know but what's happening
is lots of us effectively live in a
bodily emergency 23 percent of british
people sleep for five hours a night on
average staggering figures
and the reason this is important is
partly the bodily emergency and it's
partly
that what dr seisler had been taught at
medical school much earlier was wrong
sleep is not a passive process sleep is
an incredibly active process the way
roxanne put it to me professor prashad
is when you're sleeping you're repairing
your brain is rinsed with a a watery
fluid that carries away metabolic waste
it takes it down to your liver and gets
rid of it your brain repairs itself in
sleep the longer you sleep the better
and deeper the repairs are i mean there
are lots of other things that happen in
sleep that i talk about in the book as
well and we're not we're giving
ourselves time to repair we're not
giving ourselves time to rest and as a
result we're going around groggy
our brain isn't functioning to its full
potential so i'm saying to dr seisler
you know okay so we know that sleep's
got worse we know that sleep is crucial
for attention
um does that mean it is true to say that
we have got an attention crisis and he
said even if nothing else to change in
society and this is only one of the
twelve changes even if nothing else to
change in society that alone would be a
guarantee that we had an attention
crisis
so what do we do about it i i'm that
person i'm the
pathetic
um
i have pathetic sleeping habits for sure
for sure um so what can i do about it
you know removing my phone from the
bedroom aside the government or society
collectively deciding that
um we should they should impose better
professional
laws so that people aren't as
interrupted you know when they could be
sleeping etc what else can i do on a
real practical level so yeah at a
personal level there's plenty of
pre-commitment you can do so i would
recommend that you get a case save do
you know about them oh is that like a
safe that my phone goes in yeah so
basically it's a plastic safe with a lid
at the top you take the lid off you put
your phone in it you turn the dial at
the top and it'll lock away your phone
for anything you set it to between five
minutes and a week and if there's like a
fire or something you could easily smash
it but then you have to buy another
iphone and buy another case safe right
um so i would say an hour before you go
to bed put your phone in the case safe
and and then you can't again it's
pre-commitment you're binding yourself
so that when you're lying there in bed
and your mind's racing like oh [ __ ] i
forgot that email
too late you can't check it that's what
i do massively improve my sleep so it's
partly that that's one of the individual
changes there's also big tips and this
is one thing i recommend to you so i
went to new zealand to meet a guy called
andrew barnes so andrew uh grew up here
in london
and in the 80s he in 1987 he worked in
the city of london the financial
district uh just as the whole thing was
deregulated so the whole thing blows up
you know you've probably seen on the
news these images of like men in suits
and lots of hairspray like shouting at
each other buy buy sell cell and he was
one of those guys right and in that
world uh he was a young guy then
in in that world
you
you know this is the word language they
would have used it's not my language you
were a fool if you came to work later
than 7 30 in the morning and you were a
[ __ ] if you left before 7 30 at night
right so for half the year andrew never
saw the sun because he would had you
know leave at six o'clock in the morning
in the dark and he would get home at
nine o'clock in the morning and at nine
o'clock at night in the dark he didn't
have a good relationship with his
children he had to build that as an
adult this thing just consumed him
and he didn't like it
and wisely he quit
and he went to live in australia and
then new zealand and he became a very
successful businessman there and one day
in 2018 andrew was on a plane and he was
reading a business magazine
and he saw these quite shocking figures
which are accurate that basically they'd
done productivity research and they
discovered the average worker
sits at their desk for eight hours a day
says pre-coded obviously sits at their
desk eight hours a day but they are
actually only concentrating on their
work for three hours a day right which
are amazing figures right bad for
everyone bad for the worker their life
is passing them by bad for the employer
you know they're not getting good value
out of their employees and andrew did
this
andrew remembered this these moments
when he was working in the city and he
was exhausted and run down and he wasn't
having a life and he thought maybe my
workers are just really tired maybe
that's part of what's going on so he had
this this idea just came to him he said
if i
said the company's gonna move to a four
day week instead of a five day week for
exactly the same amount of money
and in return let's say my work is
matched this three hours a day
in return if my workers just did 45
minutes more every day of actually
concentrating
because they were better rested and so
on that would make up that then we'd be
in the same place for four hours four
days a week versus five so
andrew organized a conference call
he had uh
everyone on it
and he said
from now on i'm gonna pay you all the
same but we're gonna move to four days a
week we're gonna try it for three months
and see if it works if it works we'll
carry on doing it um andrew's head of hr
literally fell over it's like what is
this right and people even the people
who were gonna be the beneficiaries and
they were all the beneficiaries but even
the kind of lower level staff were like
is this a trick what's what's going on
how is this going to work so they spent
a few months preparing it actually made
them all think about productivity more
how are we going to make ourselves more
productive they came up with all sorts
of strategies some of them really simple
things like you know everyone has a
little pot on their desk you can put a
white flag in it when you've got the
white flag that means you don't want to
be interrupted things like that
and they tried it and uh
i interviewed everyone who worked in
their office in rotorua and this
experiment was studied by dr helen
delaney who's at the university of
auckland business school
and what they found is the company
achieved more in four days than they had
in five right productivity massively
went up stress massively went down
social media use at work massively went
down and it was fascinating talking to
the staff there about what they did one
of the things they did is they just
slept more some of them didn't take five
days i didn't take four days what they
did is they did five days but they did
six hours a day instead of eight hours a
day they slept more
they rested more
they were able to switch their brains
off from work which if you're going and
going and going is very very hard to do
and i remember interviewing them
thinking can this be true actually lots
of places have done these experiments
with four day weeks and a lot of tech
companies are offering it now as an
inducement but a lot of places did these
experiments
so microsoft in japan went to a four day
week their productivity went up by 40
toyota and gothenburg moved all their
mechanics to a six-hour day and they
produced a hundred and fourteen percent
more in in six hours than they had in
eight profits went up by 25
in a way it sounded too good to be true
right and i went to interview this guy
uh professor jeffrey pfeffer who's at
the university of stanford who's an
expert one of the leading experts in the
world on organizational behavior i was
saying well
how can that be
and he said look
it's not difficult ask any sports team
do you want your team to go onto the
pitch exhausted worn out
no
every sports fan wants their team to go
onto the pitch well rested well slept
you know so that experiment again we
won't always think about it at these two
levels what can individuals do there's a
lot
and there's the collective level where
we can make it possible for people to
make more personal changes
quick one
i can't talk about huel enough in my
life especially right now and it's
really interesting because what we tend
to see at this time of year
is the first thing that goes is our diet
quickly followed by our fitness and we
see that in the data across multiple
surveys people in the fourth quarter of
the year start indulging a little bit
more which is totally fine and they
start exercising a little bit less which
is totally fine
however a really useful crutch during
this period where the seasons have
changed and we're starting to behave a
little bit differently is making sure
your fridge is stocked with things that
are nutritionally complete healthy and
that are going to be convenient for you
to consume without compromising your
health and that is where ladies and
gentlemen
huel comes in and they now have four
brand new flavors they have the salted
caramel flavor absolutely love they have
the cinnamon swell flavor the number one
new flavor in my opinion which is really
surprising iced coffee caramel
and they have the strawberries and cream
flavor if you're going to try any of the
new flavors please do try the cinnamon
swirl and let me know what you think
it's an absolutely unexpected champion
of the new flavors
writers you're a writer that's one thing
you talk about you talk about why
reading is important and there's been a
macro decay in our reading and i
as i read that i thought why why
why is reading so important what role
does reading play we all consume
information digitally now why do we need
to go back to reading stuff
i think there's a few reasons um
and it's not again not a snooty
thing at all
so you're absolutely right that reading
is mass reading books has massively
declined um
57 of americans now never read a book in
any given year it's the first time in
the history of the american republic
that's the case we're
we're still a bit better than that in
britain but not not by much
and there's several people who really
helped me to understand this
and what that what that's doing to us
that's partly a symptom
of our declining attention and partly a
cause of it and i took a bit about how
saying to be a woman called professor
anne mangan is at stavanger university
in norway who's a professor of literacy
and probably the leading expert in the
world on on these questions
and she explained lots of things but
there's one very simple one you can do
studies have been loads of studies
showing this now
so you get group people you split them
randomly into two
the first group let's say you could do
it with my book you give one group of
people my book on the ipad like your
ipad there
and the other group you give the
physical book right and then you go back
to them a week a month a year later and
you just ask them questions about the
book
and it turns out
invariably the people who've read it on
the screen remember significantly less
and understand significantly less of
what they read this is a very well
proven effect it's called screen
inferiority it's such a big effect if
you take a ten-year-old child it's the
equivalent of two-thirds of their
progress in reading in a year
is lost when they're reading on a screen
it's that's how that's how much it
diminishes our ability to think
and it seems to be there's lots of
there's a big debate about why
but when you read let's say um you know
we opened
the bbc news site now and you me read
the same story when we read on a screen
what we tend to do is read in a sort of
skimming zed pattern you sort of skim
key words right
um
when you read a book generally we read
linearly we read from left to right you
know and you keep going
but part of the problem is if you spend
too much time reading on screens when
you read a book you start doing that
when you read books and it screws with
your ability to read books but the truth
is i think it's something more subtle
right so this marshall mcluhan was this
kind of professor in the 60s who said
this famous thing that i never
understood for years he said the medium
is the message right and what what he
meant was
when a new medium comes along he was
talking about television so a new way of
telling stories and thinking about the
world comes along
you know you could tell on your
television and you can watch the wire or
wheel of fortune or anything in between
right
the medium of television itself has a
message in it right irrespective of the
show you're watching on the television
so the medium of television the messages
the world is very fast it's all
happening at the same time
we can all think about things you get
from watching tv the way you feel if you
and i love tv things you feel when you
when you watch tv
but i think
there's a medium in the message of
social media right so think about
twitter
when you open twitter it doesn't matter
if you're donald trump bernie sanders or
i know bubba the love sponge right
there is a message you are absorbing
about how the world should be i would
say the message is firstly the world
should be interpreted and thought about
very quickly right
quick quick quick it should be
interpreted very briefly anything worth
saying can be said in very short little
bursts it's binary
exactly and what matters
the thing that is most important is
whether people immediately agree with
this very fast very short thing you've
said right that is the message hidden in
the medium of twitter right think about
instagram what's the message hidden in
the medium of instagram it's
um
what really matters is whether you look
good
and whether people like how you look
right that's it that's the message
what's the message in facebook
the message is okay friendship which is
the most precious human thing
friendship is looking at other people's
photographs of their life that you
should narrate your life to your friends
through images
and crave their likes and that that's
what friendship is mutually watching
each other's
carefully collected paparazzi images of
each other and liking them now
i think all those messages are wrong
that is a terrible way to live your life
right it is not true that life should be
interpreted quickly
actually if people immediately agree
with what you're saying
what you're saying probably didn't need
to be said at all right um yeah i like
pretty people instagram fine okay but if
that's the thing that you overweight
your life towards something's really
going wrong and friendship a true
friendship is nothing like a facebook
friendship but think about the message
the reason i say this in relation to
reading is think about the message in
the book right the printed book what
does a printed book say to you firstly
the world is complicated
and you might want to take a good bit of
time to think about one thing
secondly
it says
um you should slow down
slow down look at this thing that will
be saying the same thing 100 years from
now as it says right now right
and and thirdly it says
you might want to spend time thinking
about the inner lives of other people
because the inner lives of other people
are really interesting and you'll find
that they're like you in some ways and
unlike you in others right
so i would say take care what
technologies you absorb because over
time
your consciousness will come to resemble
those technologies you know you want to
have a life of meaning and purpose where
you engage with complex things where you
showed empathy where you showed love
these are not these are things that the
current model of social media absolutely
militates against and the books
help with they don't they're not the
solute you know they're not the sole
solution there's lots of things going on
but i i deeply believe in the medium of
the book i completely agree one of the
when i started writing my book i thought
it was insanity the concept of a book
because i'd grown up in that social
media area where you get instant
feedback etc etc and one of the like
really profound things i discovered with
a book is
because there's no comment section
no like really i think about a book if
it had a comment section below it the
comment section for a book exists on
some a website a million miles away
maybe in reviews and i really never look
at them so when someone's consuming it
they don't get to develop their opinion
based on consensus below and i've
noticed this so many times on instagram
if i post something and the top comment
takes on a certain narrative everyone
below will follow so if the top so i do
a post
people see it as it take it as it is you
can then see the behavior of them like
going into the comments section and the
minute a certain narrative emerges which
people find interesting everyone follows
that narrative and then if you i've done
it before like many years ago just
remove that comment or hide it
the narrative below changes and you can
see people actually deciding what they
think of what you're saying or whether
it's right or wrong based on the
consensus below i think it's even i
think you're absolutely right stephen i
don't know enough about comment sections
but i think in terms of commentary
online it's actually even worse than
what you just said in a lot of cases
and this is an effect of all the effects
i learned about in the book this is one
of the one that's that i think is most
harmful remember what we were saying
before which i know you know very well
that thing about the business model is
to keep people scrolling right minute
you stop scrolling they lose money all
their algorithms are designed with
literally one goal what will keep you
scrolling that's it that's the goal
right so as the algorithms in the ai
were figuring out what keeps people
scrolling
they bumped into they uncovered a human
quirk which is not the intention of
anyone at facebook or youtube or any of
these places
which is called it's a very well
documented psychological phenomenon
called negativity bias which is
basically means we will stare at
something negative longer than we will
stare at something positive anyone who's
ever been driving down the motorway and
passed a car crash knows exactly what
i'm talking about you stare at the car
crash longer than you stare at the
pretty flowers on the other side of the
road right and this is and this is
negatively biased goes very deep 10 week
old babies will stare longer an angry
face than a smiling face but when this
meets algorithms designed to maximize
the harvesting of attention this
produces a catastrophic effect and this
was this is not my view this is what
facebook itself found in its own
internal research which we've now had
leaked so imagine uh imagine this at
both a personal level and a political
level so imagine a teenager a group of
teenagers go to a party
one of them goes home
and on the bus on the way home they say
that was a really lovely party i enjoyed
it everyone looked great and they were
so nice
another teenager from the same party
posts
um
god karen looked like a right slag
tonight uh her boyfriend jim is a [ __ ]
what does the algorithm do
the second one
is more like the car crash people will
stare at it longer the algorithm will
promote it in the feed it will put it
much higher the nice one that's gonna be
way down if anyone sees it right now
that's disastrous enough at the level of
teenagers who've gone to a party now
imagine at a political level we don't
have to imagine it everyone listening
remembers who donald trump was so what
happened in the 2016 election what
happened in what's happening all over
the world every day all the time on
politics is we are being stoked to be
more angry
all the time the algorithms select for
anger because anger will keep you
scrolling right and that is destroying
our ability to solve problems and this
is not just my view in the wake of the
victory of brexit and donald trump
facebook internally set up a group of
its own data scientists called common
ground
and we now know what they found because
it was leaked and what their own data
scientists said is the facebook model
and the wider business model of social
media
inevitably causes division and
polarization that this was having
catastrophic effects it's partly what
fueled the genocide in myanmar
at burma um
and that this was in it was actually
very striking the way they put it this
was inherent to the facebook business
model and the only alternative was for
facebook to abandon its business model
and adopt what they called an
anti-growth model where they said we
won't grow as a company but we won't set
the cup world on fire right and there's
a very dry
the wall street journal who got leaked
it
they said their new story said
after he received this report mark
zuckerberg asked that he never be
brought any reports like this ever again
right so you know they know what they're
doing
the business model they're tied to their
business model they're only going to
stop doing it when we make them
but this machinery that is amping us up
into anger is just a personal first it
destroys attention when you're angry
it's much harder to pay attention we all
we've all had that experience but
there's good science for it as well
but also it's it's devastating for the
society
and we've got to deal with that i
remember doing a study i think it was
2017 i can't remember the year when
trump got elected which i presented to
coca-cola where i looked at hillary
clinton's online reach on crimson
hexagon versus trump's and it was like
12 he was reaching 12 times 12 to 15
times more people with his message
because it was centered in like really
polarizing inflammatory stuff and the
algorithm is just sending that whereas
indifference just doesn't move on social
media it's like a tree falling in the
forest with no one there well not even a
difference reasonable argument yeah who
cares you know like who's that going to
bang with it doesn't resonate with
anybody so the tribe can't pick it up
and move it for you so you're right like
the fear and anything sort of polarizing
moves really really well but i would say
i think it's a really important point
and i thought a lot about it when i was
working on stolen focus i think there
are obvious and i know you know this
much better than i do there are
huge other human motivators than fear
and anger
that we can that we can build algorithms
around right so more compelling than
fear though oh well at the moment
precisely because
this rage can be drilled into and
monetized
that's why we need regulations to stop
that hacking of the worst aspect of our
characters
which not to say there aren't legitimate
things to be angry about there are and
building algorithms around better things
right and and that's why you know people
in favor of progressive change like
ending racism in policing which is an
urgent cause
actually the emotion we appeal to most
is not rage the emotion we appeal to
most those of us who believe in that
cause
is hope and love and empathy right the
very
why why if you look at even if you think
about left-wing anger versus right-wing
anger why do these algorithms boost
right-wing anger much more than
left-wing anger and there's again this
is leaked by facebook we know this
it's because ultimately
when you're in favor of progressive
change you can't just be angry you have
to have a hopeful vision of the future
do you see what i mean yeah and we can
build this machinery around encouraging
and rewarding hope at the moment we have
it we're all plugged in to what maggie
haberman the new york times journalist
called an anger-based video game right
that's basically what twitter is and
facebook there's an amazing study by the
pew research institute that found that
for every word of moral outrage you add
to a facebook status update you double
the likes and shares right the words
that most supercharge sharing and views
on youtube
are hates destroys and obliterates right
now that is a machinery if you plug
people into that anger-based machinery
for large parts of the day the anger
doesn't go away when they put the phone
down right it's not like a release valve
it's like a it's like taking a an uh you
know a drug that amps you up right and
you're seeing that and that is degrading
our individual attention because angry
people pay attention much less well uh
it's dreading our ability to think but
it's also degrading our collective
attention right you see it's how we're
tribalizing around covid you can see
this in all sorts of ways the ways we're
tribalizing and turning on each other
about things that actually we have
perfectly sensible solutions to do you
think that it's anger-based machinery or
do you think it's plugging angry humans
into machinery because i i think i think
if you just created an algorithm which
just which had no bias at all and you
said
um
you know our objective as youtube is to
show you things that you click on more
it would only take a couple of days for
everyone's algorithm to be programmed to
show them fearful things because as you
said about the the fear bias we have and
the prehistoric evolutionary reasons why
we would want to know that there was a
line behind the rock versus one caring
if there was an ant behind the rock that
eventually because we are fear
avoiding humans we would we basically
would train in any algorithm eventually
just to show us the scary [ __ ] so there
are definitely and tristan harris i
talked to him a lot about this the
former google engineer there are lots of
alternative ways you can structure these
apps right so to give an obvious one
you could just turn off the youtube
recommendations it's not like before
they existed we were all going what will
i watch next what will i do we weren't
suddenly a lot just it's tristan says
just turn it off if the only way it can
work is that it [ __ ] people up
turn it off we don't need it it's not
that important or an alternative issue
and there are all sorts of other ways
the other ones could be structured so
twitter and we don't have to think
hypothetically twitter used to be
chronological right if you follow 200
people you open twitter the first thing
you would see is the most recent thing
that one of the 200 people you you
follow posted right you'll notice
twitter doesn't do that anymore it now
has an algorithm that selects precisely
for the things we're talking about means
twitter has become even more toxic and
even more hateful and it went wasn't
that good at the start right um
so again just go back to the
chronological even just going back to
the chronological algorithm you need a
lot more changes than that that in
itself you're right would be better so
there's all sorts of algorithms you'd
have to do to every technology company
though because no you don't this is the
thing you have to change the incentives
and then they will do it right at the
moment
all of their incentives you've got all
these smart engineers and they've got
one incentive how do i take steven's
attention the absolute most i can right
now
you change the incent they don't work
for you remember they work for the
advertisers who who
when the incentives change
then they're going to change then
obviously their behavior changes right
any business when their incentive
changes if they want to please you
rather than pleasing the advertiser then
of course the market will then provide
all sorts of ways the market the
competition at the moment the
competition is how do i maximally invade
your attention
if we move to a new business model the
competition is what does stephen
actually want if steven wants to know
where his friends are so we can have a
drink with them okay give him that
button what else does steven want steve
wants to meditate oh we'll give him that
button you can see how once they they're
figuring out what you want not what the
advertisers want then of course the
market begins to experiment and there'll
be a thousand innovations and maybe some
of those innovations will go awry and
have other negative effects and we'll
have to stop them doing that just like
you know there might be a new form of
paint that's even worse than lead paint
all right we'll ban that and we'll stick
with the one that doesn't screw people
up it feels like running around with the
uh with a fire extinguisher like
spring fight like absolutely will be
if we don't change the incentives yeah
right is that a government decision to
and what would the
legal intervention be it's pretty
straightforward you you ban the specific
mechanism of surveilling people in order
to harvest their education and sell that
to the it's not that's not complicated
it's not a legally difficult thing to do
it's a politically difficult thing to do
right we have to take on these companies
paul graham one of the leading silicon
valley investors
said the world would be far more
addictive in the next 40 years than it
was in the last 40. think about
something as simple a couple of simple
things facebook has already patented a
technology that could read your emotions
through your camera on your phone and
your laptop right
um you can see how that adds an extra
layer of how they can invade your
attention or think about something
called and i learned about this from
acer asking think about something called
style transfer really simple concept um
some people might have seen it in like
um
there's like machines that do it in
arcades in the us
so
you can take a photo any photo
and you can run it through a style
transfer program that will remake that
image in the style of vincent van gogh
or monet or you can name a painter right
so it'll just redo that picture in that
style the style transfer
but style transfer can be used in a very
different way
gmail totally legally now could scan all
of your gmail
at the ai would of course a human being
doesn't read it scan all of your gmail
and figure out the patterns of words and
the ways of talking that you reply to
you respond to most right
and then
it can sell that to advertisers so
advertisers know to approach you
using the kind of words that are
uniquely persuasive to you right now
that's going to happen if we don't
regulate that's that technology exists
um
imagine a thousand things like that are
going to be happening so it's not even
like we'll stay at the current level of
technological invasion there's
essentially a race on this aspect of the
attention crisis
between
the increasingly invasive forces of
technology which will get more and more
potent and are more potent this year
than they were last year
and would definitely be more potent a
year from now
there's that and then there's the
movement of people who are trying to
restrain this and to deal with the other
causes of the attention crisis and to me
it's a race right and it might seem like
a really big thing a movement what does
that mean when i think about that i
think about can i ask you that are you
optimistic
because i yeah i am absolutely not and
one of the the most compelling reasons
that i'm not optimistic about there
being any
um practical effective change is because
i watched the senate hearing when they
brought in mark zuckerberg and jack
dorsey and
the ceo of all these big companies jeff
bezos etc and the people who are making
the laws didn't have a [ __ ] clue
about
any social platform at all and it was
like parody in fact the videos went
viral on all social networks of these
plus 60 year old senators
trying to get their head around what
whatsapp was well they were basically
saying things like i can't find the
password for my phone well how do i get
it like bizarre
and you could see zuckerberg and dorsey
just like you could all if you look
close enough you'd see the smirk in the
corner of their mouth because they were
just like mentally bullying them they
have no idea about these technologies
and i'll be honest as someone that's
worked in this industry for a very long
time since probably
one of the few people that's been like
balls deep in this since it began
sometimes when i hear people speaking
about um
the risks
of technology and the data conversation
and all of these things
i think oh you just you've literally
just got your opinion from like reading
the newspaper and it's so much deeper
and if you just
flick that switch then
the cascading impact which you don't
understand because you can't see the
full picture is actually
this will just happen and so when i
think about the people making the laws
is kind of my conclusive point
they have no idea what they're talking
about like so you base and then the
conclusion is so you have to go and get
people from the industry to make the
laws i there is no way boris johnson
or anyone around boris johnson and i've
met some of these people could make any
real effective
change to legislation as you say when
you're talking about a race
in time
for that industry not to develop and
change and now you know they're probably
still trying to figure out the news feed
whereas these big corporations are now
talking about machine learning and ai
and they just will never keep up and
they've never been able to and now we've
got the metaverse coming and they
they're still trying to figure out if
snapchat is filters are okay and now
we're racing off into the metaverse
there's
in my opinion there is no possible
chance that technology and the pace of
change will
um be slower than the pace of effective
legislation
when i have that thought and that
thought obviously crosses my mind fairly
often
i think about something very specific
happen in my family will have happened
in your family will happen in the
families of everyone listening it's to
some degree
so i'm 42
when my grandmothers were 42 years old i
think about what the world was like
right so one of my grandmothers was a
working class scottish woman and one of
my grandmothers was a swiss woman living
on a mountain which is what would be
called sort of a peasant then right
it was legal for them to be raped by
their husbands
they were not allowed to have bank
accounts
because they were married women
in their own names
my swiss grandmother didn't even have
the vote
she needed written permission to work
outside the home which her husband would
not give her
at that time
nowhere in the world was there a woman
who ran a company
was there a woman who ran a country
there was one country
was there a woman who ran a police force
in fact there were almost no women
police officers senior women police
officers
in britain four percent of members of
parliament were women
every institution in the whole world was
run by men and had been since they were
created right
and because ordinary people
changed the culture that created
pressure on the politicians to change
the society so now
no politician would propose anything
like going back to 19 1962 1963
for women's rights it would be
unthinkable that even the most far-out
ukip candidate if they suggested that
would have to stand down right so it's
cultural change and just like the
feminist movement reclaim women's right
to their bodies and still has work to do
as we know
we need an attention movement to reclaim
our minds right we can do some of it
individually
but a lot of it we can do together at
the moment it's like someone is pouring
itching powder over us all day and then
the person pouring itching powder on us
is going
mate you might want to learn to meditate
it will stop you scratching so much
right i mean i'm in favor of meditation
it's a good thing
but someone's gonna have to take on the
[ __ ] who are pouring the itching
powder on us right
we've got to do both
so interesting because if you take on
the [ __ ] that are pouring the itching
powder there's like there's like
some knock-on effects i can see i was
thinking then about like why boris
johnson wouldn't want to impose
i was thinking as well about
recommendation algorithms which you
discussed um netflix has one youtube has
one tick tock has one everything
everything on my phone seems to have a
recommendation algorithm to get me to
buy something hang around longer
whatever trying to serve me better under
the guise of trying to serve me netflix
wants to serve you better because you
are the customer yeah so netflix doesn't
feed you in raging things netflix
doesn't show you the film that will wind
you up the most right because you are
the customer for netflix on facebook
tick tock and the others you're not the
customer
that's why it feeds you the stuff that
angers you maximally invades your
attention so there's an important
distinction between those two right and
then they're but they both have the same
incentive which is they say they are i
mean netflix famously said our only
competitor is sleepy yeah rex hastings
the head of netflix said that yeah yeah
so if like boris was to turn around
today and says i'm going to ban
recommendation algorithms or whatever
the issue he has is
it sounds like that would hurt our
chance of innovation in a global
landscape where other countries haven't
got those bans and so that would just
mean that uk tech companies were worse
yeah we've got to have bigger movements
but actually it's exact opposite a
society of people who can't focus can't
pay attention our thinking in 65 second
bursts
is not going to be an innovative society
right there's a reason why china
although i strongly oppose the communist
tyranny in china don't get me wrong why
china has just banned the amount of kids
or
very tightly restricted the amount of
time kids can spend on um video games
each week and don't allow any of these
algorithms on way about weibo and the
other things or
tightly regulate them would be more
accurate way of putting it right so if
our goal is as a country to be a country
that's innovative my god a country of
people who can think is going to be
innovative country of adult people
flicking between whatsapp snapchat and
tick tock ain't going to be a place full
of innovation right so i think
of course it's a job of explaining to
people if it was done out of the blue
now people would be baffled right so in
the same way that in you know
1962
um what you think about even just gay
people in 1962 literally nobody
including gay people suggested gay
marriage it wasn't saying anyone even
thought of right because it'd be like
it'd be so bizarre you know at that
point um well a little bit before that
being gay was a crime right
so
as you build you start to become more
sophisticated and have more ambitious
goals so at the moment we're starting
from a very basic level there's a really
interesting study that was done by a guy
called mahateri islami at the university
of illinois where he just got a load of
facebook users and just explained the
algorithm to them
and 62 of them didn't know what an
algorithm was before he taught them
through it one of them compared it to
the moment when keanu reeves in the
matrix finds out he's living in a
simulation right it blew their minds so
we're obviously a very basic level but
in terms of education because we haven't
been explaining i didn't know most of
this stuff before i did the research for
stolen focus and i didn't know about all
the other causes of uh things that are
invading our attention including some
that are much bigger actually than even
this so we have to do the work of
education we have to understand the
advantage i think we've got
is this isn't like explaining quantum
physics to someone right
we could stop anyone in the street here
in east london
and explain this to them and they are
going to get it right they can feel this
happening they can see it happening
around them so it's not that there's
in a sense the dissatisfaction and
unhappiness with all this is at the
surface
all we need to do is help people to
understand what they can do with that
dissatisfaction that this isn't just
it's not a personal failing on your part
it's really important people to
understand that if your response is
going ah
i'm just [ __ ] i'm weak i'm you know a
that's they would love you to think that
right they look they there's a constant
process of trying to transfer the blame
down to you right
so it's partly to understand it's not
your fault
it's partly to understand it's not even
the fault of technology it's the fault
of specific aspects about how our
technology works that we can change in
practical ways
that's those are the two things i think
it's really important to understand on
the about the current i mean there's
many other things and
other ways we can protect ourselves by
having more knowledge
but i think it's essential for us to
understand that because you're right
it's very easy to get into a
disempowered oh
this is so big but i'll tell you what my
grandmother's in 1962
would have a lot more reason to be to
think things could never change than we
do about tech right
i mean
it if you had shown my grandmother's my
niece's life it would have been
unthinkable these things can totally
change
james williams the google engineer i
quoted before said to me once you know
the axe existed for 1.4 million years
before anyone thought to put a handle on
it the entire web has only existed for
less than 10 000 days
we can change this thing if we want to
right we're humans and it's also about a
different disposition to this we're not
broken people and we are not
like
medieval peasants begging at the court
of king zuckerberg for a few little
crumbs of attention from his table we
are the free citizens of democracies we
own our minds we own our societies and
we can take them back if we want to we
have to decide do we value attention
people who've got children and there's
about a quarter of the book is about how
we're [ __ ] up our kids attention and
there's loads of really important things
we need to know about that that are very
different from how our schools work what
our kids eat to um the deprivation of
children being able to play but people
who've got children do you want your
child to be able to focus do you want
your child to be able to read books do
you want your child to be able to think
deeply do you want your life to have a
your child to have a life full of flow
states of course you do okay we've got
to fix the society and culture to give
them those things i feel like um
i feel like everyone listening to that
will agree and they'll all say that's a
problem i agree i want to make that
change but i think like
movements need a really specific
objective for people to rally around and
that objective is ultimately what
they're kind of taking to their
legislators or their politicians to say
this is the thing we want to change so i
would suggest three very specific if
we're going to have an attention a
movement an attention movement and
there's already lots of elements of this
fight going on and i
go through in the book how who peop who
they are and how people can join them
i would say initially three goals
uh ban this is called surveillance
capitalism ban the surveillance
capitalism business model just they
cannot track you invade you profile you
and sell your attention to advertisers
ban it very easy to do you can write
legislation in a day right
that's number one number two i would say
a four day working week the evidence is
very clear we are exhausted we are
overworked we are underslept
give people back time right covered was
the first time our society has slowed
down we've been accelerating for a long
time now we slowed down because of a
tragedy and of course none of us would
have wished for it to happen this way
but and of course there were many people
who were not able to slow down like
health workers
but
a lot of people found a real relief in
the slowness that came from covid right
we've got to slow the society down speed
destroys attention there's really good
evidence for this and the third thing is
we need to restore childhood
only 10 of children
play outside their home without adult
supervision
ever
play is how children learn to pay
attention it's how they learn to learn a
whole
body of skills come from play also just
exercise massively boosts your attention
and we've deprived our children of
exercise that's even before covid
obviously covered made it even worse for
all the obvious reasons so obviously
those are three very straightforward
goals two of them could be done with
legislation in a day right
now of course it takes a big fight to
prepare the ground for people to want
those things but they are achievable
they'll make our lives better not just
in terms of attention but in so many
ways so i'm optimistic in the sense that
there have been bigger challenges than
this yeah and human beings met those
challenges i also i think we have to be
optimistic because if we don't deal with
this
i don't think we can deal with the
bigger crises right think about the
climate crises
a group of people a species that cannot
pay attention that cannot focus
and that interacts primarily through
mediums that promote false claims and
lies so an mit study found that 19 of
the 20 most shared stories
on facebook in the 2016 election were
untrue like a false claim that the pope
could endorse donald trump 19 out of 20
just not true right
if we can't get
our focus and our ability to distinguish
uh
truth from falsehood back
how are we ever going to deal with the
climate crisis how are we ever going to
deal with
any of the problems that face us how we
can deal with our own personal problems
right we can't do that so this is the
necessary step we have to take
i think as individuals if you're facing
problems
the first step is
if you can't pay attention to the things
that matter
you're [ __ ] what can you do you can't
do anything you're just like a flailing
animal on a beach right um which is what
i always look like on a beach anyway but
um so
attention is the prerequisite to any
achievement i think
the last thing i was actually really
surprised to find in stolen focus was
you talking about food
in lost connections you talk about junk
values but in stolen focus you actually
talk about junk food and there's the
quote installed in focus where you say
we should endeavor to eat what our
grandparents would have eaten what they
would have considered real food
i loved that really resonates with me
and i've been i've been on a bit of a
crusade to try and live a little bit
more human and unless
20 20 maybe a little bit more
i don't know
9000 bc or whatever that was
so why why did you feel the need to talk
about junk food and food in a book about
attention this is one of the causes that
i learned about that i did not see
coming and it was only when i was
reading a lot of the science i was like
oh wait so there's
there's three ways in which the current
diet we eat which is completely
different to all humans before i was
eight i mean it's been an extraordinary
transformation in a very short period of
time
is is damaging our attention so dale
pinnock who's one of britain's leading
nutritionist you should um should have
him on actually he's really interesting
guy dale um so dale explained to me that
the and other scientists have shown that
the diet we eat
causes
very rapid release of energy and very
rapid crashes in energy which causes
brain fog which ruins your focus so say
for example you have and by the way i
want to say i'm completely hypocrite
saying this i literally had a mcdonald's
on the way here so just any sense of
superiority let's say you have frosties
and white bread right for breakfast what
that does is it releases a huge amount
of glucose gives you a massive rush of
energy feels great for about 20 minutes
and then you're sitting at your desk or
your kids sitting at their desk and the
glucose crashes and you're just in brain
fog right so one way is it the way dale
puts it is you know if you put
um rocket fuel into a mini it would go
really fast for a minute and then it
would just putter out and we're
basically doing that and as he put it to
me if you're eating sort of shitty
carbohydrates every meal
you're doing that to yourself again and
again and again all throughout the day
the second way in which it harms our
attention
our current diet deprives us of
nutrients that are necessary for your
brain to develop right there's an
interesting study by dutch scientists
where they got a bunch of kids they did
this several times and it replicated
well they got a bunch of kids
and they put one of them on what they
called an eliminationist diet where they
basically didn't eat any processed food
and the other group of kids just ate
normally and the kids that were put on a
on with cut out all the processed food
and all of that
that 70 of them had significant
improvements in their attention
and their average improvement in
detention was 50 so really big
improvement
the third cause
is that it's not just that our food
lacks things we need
is that it contains things that act on
us like drugs there's a really shocking
study on this it's done in southampton
here in britain in 2007. they got nearly
300 kids they were seven year olds and
12 year olds
and they split them into
two groups
and the first group was given a drink
that just contained
dyes that exist in normal food like m
m's you know synthetic dyes and the
other group i think i can't if it's just
water or it was some kind of flavoring
that doesn't contain these dyes
and then they were monitored and the
kids that drank the dyes that kitten
every day and i'm eating every day
were significantly more likely to have
attention problems struggle focusing so
you've got these three ways and you
mentioned you know this this big change
about how our ancestors i mean i
remember when i was a
as i said my my my dad's from
switzerland um i grew up on this in this
little hut in a mountain in switzerland
and when i was a kid it started when i
was nine
my dad that bastard sent me his very
nice man in many ways sent me every
summer to go and stay on this farm where
he'd he'd grown up he's like go to the
farm you've become a man he said um
and i would arrive there and to me this
was like i grew up in edward right
suddenly on a swiss mountain it's like
what's happening right
um
and i remember my so my grandparents ate
how almost all humans in almost all of
our history have eaten they would grow
their own food and they would kill their
own animals right and eat them
and i remember my my grandmother used to
just put food in front of me i remember
the i remember very clearly the first
day i was there looking at it because i
grew up you know i was raised mostly by
my scottish grandmother working class
scottish women i grew up eating
microwave chips and fried food and you
know i remember looking at the food my
swiss grandmother gave me
and literally saying
where is the food
this isn't food
and then just being completely puzzled
so for like two weeks i didn't i ate
almost nothing and then finally she
cracked and took me to the mcdonald's in
zurich which is pretty far away and i
remember i was sitting at mcdonald's and
her looking at it and her saying but
this isn't food what are you talking
about she just couldn't understand why i
would want to eat it and so in three in
two generations there was a huge change
we went from eating mostly fresh and
nutritious food to mostly most peop most
british and american people
most of their diet now consists of
processed or ultra processed food which
is just really different it's just very
different i mean the food writer michael
pollan who i know
said we shouldn't call it food we should
call it food-like substances
because it doesn't resemble food now
again this is one of the other causes
bit like the four day week
i can tell you all the facts
can i do it no
you know i mean i'm a bit better than i
was but only a bit so to um to end we're
going to continue with our new tradition
which is asking you the question that
our previous guest left for you
and the previous guest that sat here
wrote in the diary
what was
the best conversation
you ever had
and why
oh that's a very good question i'm not
meant to talk about this but i'll i'll
i'll talk a little bit about it
i
am getting emotional a bit emotional
about this uh try not to um
the last 10 years i've been researching
a book about
a series of crimes that have been
happening in las vegas and i'm not meant
to talk about it too much
and
there's a couple who lived beneath
caesar's palace in the drainage tunnel
beneath his palace
called tommy and shea who i got to know
incredibly well
who are two of the people i've most
loved in my life i remember standing
above where their tunnel is and shade
and shade just saying
all these people
they're so much closer to where we are
than they think
not just physically but
a few things go wrong
and
in that society you're in a [ __ ]
tunnel and i remember that night with
tommy and shay
and i must have heard that i think i was
with them for like 12 hours that day
uh
i think that's one of the best
conversations i've ever had there shay
is so wise
uh tommy is so f was so funny
and they taught me so much about
in all the years i knew them for how to
be a person and tommy was murdered last
year it's one of the reasons why i spent
a lot of the plague in vegas because
i've been trying to
help shay and figure out what's going on
what happened um
and
i think that's one of the best
conversations in my life i i think they
are
they they taught me to
think about life differently
and
every day i integrate some lesson that
tommy taught me and i think that's one
night i mean there's so many nights we
spent together but
that's one night that really stands out
for me i mean i can think of lots of
others but that's the one that
you know it's amazing the remarkable
thing about your writing which makes it
so engaging and compelling is it isn't
assigned to shouting facts and figures
at you which i just as someone that
struggles to read anyway i have to have
a captivating emotional journey to take
me through these subjects for me to be
able to ingrain them in my conscious so
um your books all do that especially
this one especially lost connections
which is one of my all-time favorite
books by the way but stolen focus is a
is a an amazing somewhat linked uh
sequel in many respects and on many
topics to that book and that was my
favorite ever and this is one of now one
of my favorite books as well because uh
it's one of the books that i managed to
actually read in the last year
because of the way you write and that's
a huge credit to you um there's a reason
i always bring you back on this podcast
i love these conversations great um and
you've been uh and off camera you're
you're
you know you probably should be a
comedian because you're so hilarious but
on camera you're such an intelligent
human being and
off camera you're funny you're
intelligent you're not so off-camera
but uh you're an incredible human being
and i love i love having you here so oh
thanks again for giving me this time and
i'm so i'm so glad that um we're able to
have this conversation because it's such
an important one and one that i need i
needed in my life i really appreciate
you how deeply you pay attention to the
book and um i'm meant to say or my
publishers will tell me let's do it that
um anyone who wants to know where to get
the audio book the ebook or the physical
book can go to stolenfocusbook.com and
on the website you can listen for free
to loads of the experts we talked about
like the guy who discovered flow states
uh
all these google experts
a ton of people
um i'm meant to read something where i
say like read it also i can't bring
myself to it makes me sound like a [ __ ]
something like you can find out what
stephen fry hillary clinton and many
other leading experts thought about the
book um something like that hillary
clinton's read the book she has she's
something a very nice
thing um
yeah
and lots i mean so sad there's there's
an alternate universe where hillary
clinton is in her second term as
president and unfortunately instead
she's in a world where she has to read
my book instead but um i would rather
live in the i'd rather live in a bit
where we got to skip trump but nevermind
um the yeah so and you can get the book
in all good bookshops you can even get
it in [ __ ] book shops and it's out right
now it's available it's just come out so
go and read it thank you so much steven
i really thank you
honestly that you came and did this
again
[Music]
[Music]
you